yes i hear you
let me introduce you well uh
the first speaker for for the afternoon
session is pascal bontobel this is
correct
yes
from this
close close enough
he's going to speak out on politics and
convex sets associated with classic
graphical models in cip and qip
okay good afternoon everybody um here in
hong kong it's middle of the night but
anyway it's a great pleasure to attend
this conference uh i would like to start
by thanking the the organizers for
putting together this nice workshop i've
been enjoying very much learning new
stuff
i'm probably not the typical attendee so
my background is in electrical
engineering
and uh so i've been more precisely
working in coding and information theory
and within that a lot in reliable
communication and reliable data storage
but in recent years i've been also
interested in quantum information
processing so what i'm presenting here
is probably quite a bit different from
uh
maybe using different terminology from
uh what is used otherwise here in uh
in this uh
workshop but i hope there are enough
connections and i try to include enough
background materials so so i put more
emphasis on uh you know putting enough
background material uh so that you can
understand uh things i think there are
quite a few connections especially to
things that have been uh presented on
monday
that i were some of them new to me and
uh maybe there are some
some things in my presentation that are
new to you and or possibly of interest
okay so let me get started here
yeah so uh the main objects that i would
like to talk about are so called the
marginal polytope and the local marginal
correct
okay
and they will appear both in classical
information processing quantum
information processing now the local
marginal polytope this has nothing to do
with uh local physical series so don't
confuse this is some different locality
it has nothing to do with local
physicals and one of the main
concepts that
we see that are used for so-called
graph covers more precisely topological
graph course
i'm being here more precise because in
computer science there are other graph
colors like vertex graph colors or edge
graph covers so i'm here a bit more
precise that i'm using topological graph
so you can see that in what sense
they're useful and there are actually a
lot of uh
at least i think there are a lot of uh
uh
things connections to stuff we have seen
on monday uh the type of graphs and
modifications of grass that we have seen
on monday so uh
okay uh let me motivate things that i
would like to do in this presentation
sorry for the typo here
uh so uh yeah let x1 x2 x3 x4 be some
arbitrary finite sets it can just be in
the simplest case it can just be that
binary set so that would be the simple
set would be xi's just a
little one
that would be good enough
okay and what we look at is a random
variables x1 x2 x3 x4 that take values
in this set here and i'm assuming that i
have a joint probability mass function
pms stands for probability mass function
okay so i have here a john pms so what i
do here on this slide is undergraduate
probability series so nothing uh
particularly difficult
so obviously when we have a joint pmf
here we can define marginal pmfs and
here i've just written down some of them
here we have uh
yeah if i'm summing over x4 here after
margin over x1 x2 x3 right and if i'm
summing over x3 x4 and i get just a
marginal over x 1 x 2 and if i'm summing
over x 2 x 3 x 4 i get here the margin
over x 1 and so on you can define many
other uh marginal pms okay of course
these are all pms because this was a pmf
these will all be pms
so this is totally standard uh
undergraduate probabilities here
okay
uh let me simplify the notation so this
is exactly the same slide as the
previous slide but here you see instead
of p of x 1 x 2 x v x 4 i will just
write p 1 2 3 4
and here instead of p x 1 x 2 x 3 i will
write here you know 1 2 3
okay it's exactly the same but that's
kind of the notation that i will use
from now on
okay and uh yeah so i define here
something that i call the marginal
polytope uh
first i actually need some sets here uh
these are some one two three four
because i have random variables x one x
two extremes four and here are certain
pairs of random variables that i care
about
there are some pairs that are not listed
here so this is only a subset of the
possible pairs that i'm looking at
yeah so what i define here a marginal
polytope that i'm collecting here these
modules and they should be induced by
some joint pms so i'm assuming that in
the background there is some joint pmf
over x1 x2 x3 x4 and that these guys
induce this pms
exactly that they computed them on this
slide here
okay so this is one possible marginal
product of course there are many other
marginal prototypes that i could define
but but that's the marginal polytroph
that i'm defining here for making an
example
okay now uh yeah obviously as the name
suggests this is a polytope one can
easily verify this you know there are
some inequalities uh constraints and
some equality constraints overall it
will be uh for it of its founded set so
it will be a problem okay no big
surprise
okay and let me emphasize that these
these functions these marginal pmfs that
are collected here they have to satisfy
some consistency constraints for example
if i'm taking p12 and i summary x2
then i should get p1 x1 right or if i
take p14 and i sum over x4 well then i
should also get p1 x1 right and so so so
these are uh natural consistency
constraints that have to be satisfied
okay so far everything is totally
standard
and uh yeah
so this was the definition that i had
before of the marshall polytope and i am
introducing what i call here the local
marginal point open
okay so on the left hand side i have
kind of the same thing here but now the
big difference is there is no joint pms
that induces these things so i'm just
restoring i'm just requiring that pi is
a pmf
pij is a pmf
and that these consistency constraints
that i had on previous page these
consistency constraints here that they
are satisfied
okay
yeah it should be clear that uh you know
um
every every
every collection of functions here that
appears here will also be here
you know because they satisfy the
consistency constraints so every every
every vector here of functions every
collection of functions here will also
appear here okay so this is clear that
the marginal polytope is a subset of the
local marginal property should be a
curly hair
okay now but the big question is uh
are they the same or is they strict
subsets
now interestingly enough uh they're
desperate substance okay so that
typically happens
you could come up these scenarios but
it's the same that the typically what
happens is uh they're different there's
so l is uh strictly larger than n1
yeah and
my talk is essentially about now uh
obviously yeah typically what happens is
m is a strict subset of l and i want to
discuss the implications of that
first of all i want to discuss the
implications of that in classical
information processing uh we'll first
talk about the sum product algorithm and
uh which is equivalent to loop people
leave propagation uh
and see how that can be characterized by
this local marginal polytope
and then we will see also uh how this
has relevance for quantum information
processing and is that we can understand
bell's game is that we get into this you
know the way we can think of causality
also the quantum set so that will be the
connection to the the theme of also the
the workshop
so well yeah i hope everybody
understands here the different
difference between the marginal polytope
and the local marginal prototype so here
the multiple people it has to be induced
by some joint pmf whereas here in
general uh you know there might not be a
joint pmf right so this might be
strictly bigger and this typically
happens
yeah
and that's that's what i want to discuss
here and i already mentioned the uh
graph covers and we'll see how they're
useful towards understanding this
locomotion
yes
uh where is the question or
we will i will read to you uh
maybe i could just speak it can you hear
me
i'm just curious whether
are there examples where they're
the same so if i think of
anything non-trivial like three bits it
seems there's already a gap so yeah
yeah there are there are uh yeah i mean
not not in the way i have defined i mean
there are you know this is just one
possible marginal polytope so there are
uh things and this is in the you know
this is a topic in optimization it's
really the topic in optimization theory
where people look at the relaxations and
then people talk of a tight relaxation
then there is no difference between the
lower local marginal problem and the
module
so yeah not yet the way i have here
defined
usually there is a gap
but there are other ways to define the
marginal problem
so i don't you know i wanted to keep
things simple here uh yeah so it's a
very good question so so there are
interesting cases where it is said okay
well if you have time later it'd be nice
to see yeah i i can give you a point
okay
thank you for the question
okay uh yeah so now in order to uh you
know my language that uh
i've worked a lot on graphical models uh
particle factor graphs so might be
different than uh you know that you most
of you using i don't know exactly it's
only a bit different than directed at
cyclic grass but i hope they're not so
different so that you feel comfortable
pretty soon
okay so the way we represent what we're
doing when we talk of a factor graph we
represent the multivariate function this
is a graph what i do i draw variable
nodes these are round nodes here these
are variable nodes so x1 is associated
with this here and here this is
associated with x2 i think some and this
is what i call a functional thing this
should be actually f
should be f
okay
so uh yeah so this uh this is what this
function represents so we have variable
node function nodes and we have edges
between variable nodes and functions
now this is not terribly interesting yet
here uh it really gets interesting once
we have here we know something about the
internal structure of uh
okay
so uh once we know something about the
internal structure of g like we know a
factorization things become much more
interesting and then uh what i have here
i have variable notes x1 x2 x3 and our
function functionals f a and fb and i
make here the connections according to
what is an argument of water so fa has
arguments x1 x2 right so so that's why i
have connections like this here and fb
has arguments x2 and f3 and so that's
why i make it a connection
okay notation-wise or language-wise i
called here the global function and
these are local functions
again this has nothing to do with local
physical series or anything
okay and of course you can do uh even
fancier things right uh yeah here i have
a global function of five variables so
here are five variable notes then and
here i so happen to have five local
functions
here the connections according to what
is in our so fc has argument x1 x2 x3 so
i have here a connection to x1
connection to x2 and
and of course i can redraw things so
that things look more pleasing
it should be clear
does that make sense
so these are what i call factor graphs
and of course this is related sorry we
have a question
yes sorry it's a very quick question you
always have a product structure
for g in terms of the effort can you
imagine something else
yeah you can in general what i need is a
semi ring so that's what i need
ultimately
for doing things so here i have a
product structure and then what i do i i
do summations
but you can generalize this to anything
i reckon so here i have a yeah products
and summation but yeah you can
generalize it okay
yeah the algebraic terms is semi-re
that's what i need so i what i need is
commutativity commutativity is very
important
and
distributivity
but i don't need any inverses or stuff
like i don't need any additive or
multiplicative inverses
so the formalism that i'm presenting
here is very generous so as long as you
have a semi semi ring it works
okay and yeah
many of you are working on bayesian
networks and these types of things so uh
yeah you can effectively for any any
graph you can draw a corresponding
factor graph and if i got it right this
is what would what it would look like so
uh you know i would have to introduce
this would be a prior here on z
uh if there is such a prior and here
this would be the conditional
probability of x given u and z and this
would be the conditional probability of
y given u and x
okay so that's what a factor graph
corresponds to so effectively yeah for
any
any um
any asian network or director cyclic
graph i can draw something like this i
hope that makes sense
so my graphs are they don't have direct
here these are undirected graphs
okay but the big difference is i have
variable notes and they're function
nodes and they have only connections
between uh variable nodes and functions
just a quick clarification question
why do you not have four functions
sorry why do you only have three
functions there
uh should there be more
you have got four variables like zx umi
oh it can be you know you can have
n you can have in general n variable
nodes and m functionals right i mean
they don't have to be the same amount
um
[Music]
i mean i could have a pri i guess i
could have also prior here on you i mean
yeah i could have a prior on you i guess
so i could have a prayer on you a few
moments
so we can ask another question
if you had a connection between you and
zed would you end up with the same
factor graph if the immorality
disappeared
so here you would have uh
yeah then i would have to modify my
factory graph of course right then i
don't know this would be i would have to
modify this correspondingly right
i don't think there's a kind of
one-to-one mapping between fact yeah and
basic networks
okay yeah i mean this is yeah but i hope
at least the example that i gave here
makes sense okay
but yeah i think you know ultimately you
should be able to represent you know
whatever you present here you should be
able to represent but uh yeah i'm
you know i'm happy to see yeah
yeah the important thing is that if you
have never seen a graphical model like
this
hopefully makes sense anyway typically
the setups that i care about we have
thousands of variables or even ten
thousands of variables and ten thousands
of functional so so i'm mostly
interested in techniques that work for
huge setups that's what we use when we
do actually data communicate so as i
said in the introduction and
one of the things i care about is
reliable data communication so what we
have here is the source
that is the vector of the information
the picture or data file that you want
to transmit
and we have a channel that can be a
wireless communication channel or
something like that or which you
transmit with your mobile phone and in
order to achieve reliable communication
we do not send it directly over the
channel what we do is we do some channel
coding so we add some redundant
information so that even if some errors
happen
we can correctly decode stuff so so here
i'm doing some encoding and then here i
can
you know i receive something and then i
do the decoding and then i have an
estimate
so this is about the reliability and
this is nothing but there's no
cryptography now i talk about codes this
is in codes in the sense of achieving
reliable communication of cryptography
okay anyway
think of here you have typically like
1000 bits
you might encode them into 2000 bits
that you send over channel and then you
receive 12 000 bits and you want to
estimate these thousand bits
okay and yeah one of the coding schemes
that have been proposed is so-called low
density parity check codes that was by
gallagher in his phd seasons at 1090
that was in the 60s and he actually uh
yeah he actually proposed kind of an
early version of loopy belief
propagation over some product algorithm
uh but yeah back then the computation
the resources were very limited and so
uh yeah not much was done on this and uh
yeah these codes were only discovered in
the 1990s once once computers become
more powerful and nowadays uh yeah uh
they know the five gta communications
that's the latest tech communication
standard
and yes so uh these codes can be
represented with this factor graphs and
the way it works that the you know some
algorithms running on on these
photographs
so yeah in your mobile phone if you have
a 5g mobile phone you have this this in
the background so to speak you have a
such a factor graph and some algorithms
running on that
so the calculation that we need to do is
is something like this here where we
have here we need to estimate something
here and
so here we have to join pmf and the
problem is really to compute here some
margin that's that's what we're
computing here we compute some more
and that is the the difficult part here
and the idea is that we represent the
whole thing here is a factor graph
and then we use the sum product
algorithm to exactly or approximately
compute the margin
yeah this is just very high level a
presentation here this is just to give
you a flavor of the things
that i'm doing here
okay now i already mentioned the sum
product algorithm that's we need that to
compute these modules so let me briefly
say what is this at least give a high
level of view what this sum product
algorithm is so remember this example
here that i have here this is this
factor graph so here i have global
function
that is the product here of this local
function so it's exactly the same that i
had before
and what we typically interested in
computing marginal functions okay we try
to we have here the global functions and
we need to sum over all the variables
so think of this to be a pmf probably
mass functions and i need to compute
them certain modules
and it's the same thing here this is a
different motion and really the
applications that i care about we have
like thousands of variables so so i
cannot do any brute force calculations
so they will never ever work so i need
to be smart about and the question is
can i be smart about ever waiting here
this summation here
that's the question and that's what the
sum product algorithm answers so i have
no time to go through all the details
the nice thing is when we have a factory
graph without cycles
then we have a very nice
procedure where we send messages
messages are nothing else than functions
or partial results that are sent here
and first compute like this message and
then based on this message i compute
this message and so on
i have no time to discuss any details
here the the point is this is a very
nice locally operating algorithm based
on which like if i compute the module i
combine here the local the available
messages and that's that's that's
and yeah this is also known as belief
propagation by pearl and uh
and also it's nothing else than dynamic
programming you can think of dynamic
programming
the important thing is this all the
computations are done locally so so here
i take in the incoming messages and i
produce new messages
and once you analyze you know different
scenarios it's always the same
calculation so this is at the variable
note that's the calculations that i do
here to based on the incoming messages i
produce in the outgoing message and
that's what i do here at the function
again i have absolutely no time to go
through details the important thing is
that all the processing is done locally
so this function node here takes the
incoming messages does some calculation
and produces an outcome messaging the
same thing for a variable node it takes
incoming messages and produces an
outgoing message
and one can show that if we have a
scenario like this here where we have no
cycles
then we get the correct motions so this
is very efficient and also exact
and this has many important applications
in practice like kalman filtering can be
seen as such a calculation okay and this
is what i do here when i do the marginal
is just combining the locally available
but local incoming
messages
okay however when it comes to coding
theory we need to use good codes now i
have not told you what a good code is
in terms of minimum distance and so on
uh this is way beyond discussion here
the the important thing is there will be
cycles if you want to have a good code
you need cycles in your graph okay
so uh what people do is then they use
still the sum product algorithm despite
the fact there is no justification so
the thing is
for the graph that i have here there is
a lot of just you know it's there's
perfectly justified i get the correct
modules at the end of the algorithm so
everything is as it should be
sufficient we get the exact modules
but again as i said unfortunately for
for for us for to have a good code we
need some we need factory grass with
cycles uh but then what we do is we just
apply the the algorithm because it's a
local algorithm right it just takes the
incoming messages and it produces
outgoing messages so what we do here
uh what we do here we
we have here variable notes where we
take the incoming messages we produce
the outcome messages and then we do
updates here at the functions and then
we hit right here
so here why this is the up from the
channel observations uh yeah and then we
update here and at the end
i have absolutely no time to go much
into details but uh
so so that is what is done uh ldpc codes
and the 5g telecommunication center
that's what is done and the question is
why does it work that's the big question
why does it work there is absolutely
no justification again as i said here
the derivation is perfectly fine
mathematically here
for this one when there is no cycles but
when i have
cycles there is absolutely no
justification why the algorithm works as
well as it does
and then you know can we come up with a
justification why it works
okay uh yeah so now i'm coming to this
graph covers that i introduced that i
talked about in the introduction so
and i think there is quite some relation
to some stuff we have seen on monday so
yeah
there's a question
so would be interesting uh maybe
afterwards discussion on that
okay what is a graph cover and more
precisely what is a topological graph
so consider here a graph like this here
okay
and uh you know uh what i'm
okay
so what uh what is now a double c let me
tell you what is a double cup so here i
have a graph with four vertices and here
i have what i call in a double cover or
two-fold cover okay and what i do here i
double all the vertices
so this vertex is doubled here this
vertex is doubled here and so on okay
and what do i do i also double every
edge so what you see here this edge here
will become either like an edge like
this here or two edges like this so let
me fix it like this here
and then this edge here becomes two
edges either like this here or
like this here so let me fix it like
this here
and for this edge again i have two
possibilities
uh again i'm fixing that this here this
edge here has
this possibility of this possibility
again i'm fixing like this here and
finally uh this one has also two
possibilities
either zero this
so there are lots of double covers okay
you can actually easily count them here
in this case there are 32 of them
because for every edge there are two
possibilities
now the important thing is that the
locality these graphs look the same
that's why i care about this because
somebody if i'm looking here right
locally
they behave exactly these two copies
here they behave locally exactly the
same the way they're connected to the to
the other part of the graph or if i'm
looking at this here uh you know it
looks the same here and here these two
copies that's the idea that's why i care
about these graph colors
okay and of course you can also define
triple cover so in a triple cover what i
will do i will simply uh
triple all the verticals all the
vertices and for every edge like here
there will be three edges so for every
edge there will be three edges and there
will be uh here three factorial
possibilities
okay and so you can go on and on and on
so there will be uh
and in general there will be m fold
covers
and yeah maybe you already see some
connections to what was presented on
london
okay
and yeah if you have enough time you can
draw all the all the graph covers so
here this is the base graph and then you
can draw double covers here and then you
you can draw here all the triple cover
sensors so there is a whole hierarchy of
graph codes
so that's that's that's the concept of a
graph called
now why are these uh relevant let's look
again like a coding setup here this is
again my channel observation uh these
are my code bits here and these are the
restrictions on one to define my code
here and what i do i run the sum
productive for loopy belief propagation
and uh yeah so uh
excuse me you have 10 minutes huh
sorry you have 10 minutes okay tell 10
more minutes okay yes so uh what happens
here is that uh yeah i'll do this some
product algorithm right
and uh yeah as i discussed fine before
and the thing is uh it's a local
algorithm right it takes incoming
messages produces outgoing messages
right
now let's look at the triple cover
and let me run you know the belief
propagation here right i can run the
belief propagation here in the upper one
right or i can write it here now the
interesting thing is because of the way
i do the calculations
i do exactly the same calculation in a
in a in a graphical so that's the
interesting thing now that happens
because locally they look exactly the
same thing here uh
what happens is that actually the
message that was computed here is
computed here three times and the
message that is computed here is
computed here three times and so so so
in fact uh in some sense i can actually
not distinguish if i'm actually decoding
you know the code described by the above
factor graph or the code described by
the the lower factor graph
so that's kind of
that's a way to think about why why uh
the sum product algorithm is suboptimal
doesn't work quite as
as it should be ideal
so it's a way to understand what's
actually going on and the interesting
thing one can make this precise okay so
this uh so far these have been kind of
philosophical uh remarks uh but we we
can actually make this precise so that's
the interesting thing here
yeah so the thing is uh you know uh
yeah
any locally operating album cannot
distinguish if it's actually the
original factor graph and any of its
cores there was actually a discussion
at the end of a talk on monday there was
kind of something similar uh
somebody presented something there and
it's kind of very very much related to
that what i'm doing here
okay uh yeah
and so in some sense i have to study all
the covers all possible covers and all
the possible codewords so at first it
seems to be a terrible task
uh
but interestingly enough
we can actually characterize what's
going on and the answer is actually
exactly this local margin
so that's that's now one of my first
conclusions here of my
presentation why i do what i do here it
turns out if you want to understand
loopy belief propagation uh this local
marginal polytope is is a very useful uh
thing to understand and so so yeah uh
and we have seen the lo you know
remember what we had at the beginning
right so uh m
is yeah strictly a subset of l right and
because we have this uh yeah
and also understanding the gap if we
understand the gap between the two we
also understand how sub-optimal uh the
algorithm is
i have absolutely no time to go more
into details i just wanted to uh you
know uh
point out these results here uh that one
can you know
do these titles calculations okay here
are some references
let me also point out that uh there is a
person called angerwin
back in the 1980 he had exactly
philosophically exactly the same
observation for different setups so so
they looked at networks of processors
so the philosophically they started
exactly the same
uh but ultimately the conclusions they
reach are quite different
so if you're interested you can look up
that paper from 19b so philosophically
they do exactly the same but ultimately
the calculations are very very different
okay let me now uh in the last minutes
six seven minutes let me talk about uh
you know
how this local marginal prototype is
relevant in quantum information process
so the thing is we can also use factor
graphs to do uh quantum information
processing
and
here i will use the so-called variant of
factor graphs that are called normal
factor graphs so here i have all the
variable nodes of degree one that is the
number of uh you know h is incident on
on that variable is either one or two
okay i can actually you might think this
is a restriction but actually turns out
uh there is no loss of generality so if
this is not satisfied i can reformulate
my factor graph so that this is
satisfactory
and what i will do because uh the way
things are i can just omit the the
variables i don't draw them so so i end
up with something like this here that i
can use in uh quantum information
processing so again if i in a standard
factor graph i would have here a
variable node here and so on
and so on but i'm omitting them because
they're all degree
anyway uh one can show that you know any
if you're looking at the standard
textbook of nielsen and chuang and so on
you can for any problem that appears
there you can draw a corresponding
factor graph so here is an example where
i prepare something in some state that
is represented here by a row which is a
density matrix here and then i have here
unitary evolution so here is u0 this is
a unitary matrix then here i do a
measurement on part of the system then
here have a unitary evolution more and
again i do some measurement there's some
more unitary motion this is just some uh
interesting example
what you get here if you define here all
the functionals properly the good thing
is once you take the global function so
this defines obviously has a global
function right it's the product of all
the local functions here and now if i
sum over all the x variables i just
leave out you have just the y's that i
don't sum over yeah if you do everything
properly you get just here p of y one y
which is the probability of observing
measurement results y one and one two
okay
okay i have absolutely no time to to
explain here details but the point is
i can you know define such uh such
graphical models to do a quantum
information processing and i get then
the quantities of interest by computing
suitable margins
and here's the reformation anyway so uh
yeah so let's look at the global
function of such a normal factor graph
i call this a quantum mass function this
is a strict generalization of uh of a
probability mass function it's more
general
and uh yeah it's very similar to a pmf
but it's a bit different and so in a in
a pmf we would also have in a
probability mass function we would also
get one right if we sum over everything
right so we would have that but here
what we have this is a complex value
and it also has to be here it has to be
a psd kernel
so it's it looks very similar to a
quantum you know to probably the mass
function but it's a bit different
okay yeah anyway as i said uh basically
if you take the book by nissan chuang
you can go through all the examples and
you can draw the corresponding factor
graph and so there are all the
calculations that you know to understand
this graphical
this this processing can be done by
analyzing these graphical models
suitably
okay now what i want to do is uh the
following you see here whether the
interpretation actually let me actually
go back here to this this graph here the
x's i can think of this to be kind of
quantum variables
and the y's here are kind of uh
uh they're kind of classical variables
also x is my quantity they characterize
kind of my uh quantum system but as the
y or kind of measurement results
and so in some sense this is like a you
know copenhagen setup right um you know
i have some quantum stuff and i have
some classical stuff right and you know
there is
some relationship between them
that's what's written here uh right so
we have on one hand we have kind of
quantum variables and we have classical
variables okay
yeah so the question is can i somehow
get rid of the classical variables
ideally you know the way at least i
think you know the world is that it's
really a quantum you know the physics
you know the world that we live in is
really a quantum system and somehow uh
you know the classical variable emerges
and this is actually possible so we can
actually get rid of of this y and then
we can study just functions q x and x
prime
and we call them the simple quantum mass
function and they have to satisfy these
properties
so uh let me actually point out this is
actually very very tightly related to
something called the coherence function
so philosophically the way we started is
quite a bit different but ultimately
mathematics is very very tightly related
to what is known as the coherence
function and
there is here by gelman which is a
physics
novel already and also it's related to
consistent quantum theory and what i'm
doing here
okay the the point is you can now study
uh this qms and you can study these
marginals and then again this marginal
correct open this local margin
so so let me uh that's now the last few
minutes of my presentation let me give
you an examples how how how this local
marginal product arise and you know what
is the relevance i'm afraid you have to
you have to start closing yeah yeah i'll
just wrap up so what i have here is is a
quantum mechanical setup here
and uh yeah so that defines here such a
simple quantum mass function here and
the point is here in general when i i
can represent all the entries of these
functional values by some matrix now in
general this will not be a diagonal
matrix
however interestingly enough if i'm
looking at certain marginals there will
be diagonal matrices this will be
different and then in that sense if if i
have a diagonal i call these classical
variables also they're jointly classical
x1 and x2 and here x1 x3 and x 2 x so
the interest that's the point here
interestingly enough what what can
happen is that we have here a you know a
setup where overall x1 x2 x3 they're not
jointly classical but the marshals if i
just look at x1 x2 they're classical we
found x1 x3 the classical and x2 x3
they're classical so so it's kind of uh
something similar happening to to kind
of did this uh
you know the local marginal
type of thing right where we have kind
of marshals
that are you know by themselves
consistent but there is no uh you know
joint pmf of everything
okay yeah i have no time to to go uh all
the details here uh the point is you can
then analyze uh uh
here uh you know
bell's game with in the in that in that
setup yeah we have here uh some
marshmallows that the prize the
characters game and the key point is
there is no uh joint pmf of the whole
thing
and we can in the same spirit we can
analyze hardest paradox
we can also analyze fraukhinger regular
paradox which was
2018.
okay anyway the key point is there is
something called the marginal prototype
and there is something called the local
marginal prototype and usually they're
distinct and the distinctness
has a lot of implications i've given
implications in the classical world when
we analyze the system product algorithm
and i've given some implications for the
uh quantum mechanical world and yeah one
way to put on to understand this local
marginal political is actually via these
covers because uh points in this uh
marshall prototype can be characterized
by valid configurations in these scopes
that's a
mathematical theory
again i think there are lots of
connections to things
that have been presented on monday but
that would be way beyond what i have
time to discuss here
okay uh yeah so thank you very much for
your attention thank you much for your
time and yeah just a little
advertisement so uh as i said one can
use graphical models to do all sorts of
quantum information processing and i've
done this uh you know i have a course
that you can look at here on this
website
uh other people have also done uh you
know graphic model approaches to the
quantum information processing but i
don't think it has been done
so early on in that spirit
okay so thank you very much again for
all for your kind attention and yeah let
me know if you have any questions
either now or you're also welcome to
contact me by email later on okay thank
you very much
question
just one really quick question in the
the point where you said that the cover
of the the um
the low density parity check code you
said that the cover and the original
thing uh they they couldn't distinguish
between uh
which uh that locally they couldn't tell
which code word was being done
yeah could is that i mean i was confused
by that a little bit because you've got
obviously more more bits in the i mean
yeah i mean you need to define yeah i
have absolutely no time to discuss the
details right so yeah i mean first of
all what i did here is just uh you know
a philosophical statement right so
intuitively right because things are
done locally and you know the grass look
locally the same so to speak the decoder
cannot distinguish am i decoding this
code or this code you know the code is
described by the base graph or the code
described by the any of the covers right
yeah now uh the good thing is uh you can
actually make things rigorous so that's
you you have to look at my paper we can
also discuss it uh but yeah so the what
i've presented here is just a
philosophical background but the good
thing is you can actually make things
mathematically rigorous uh that you
defined and suitably i mean yeah what
you do is you you look at the uh
you know if you have a if you have a
code word in a cover you will have to
project it down
some suitable projection operators also
that it makes sense so yeah it's way
beyond what i can discuss here uh but
yeah the good thing is one one can make
it precise and uh yeah one gets uh
one gets and yeah just let me mention
the terminology there's something called
the beta problem so this or what i've
talked about here is also known as the
beta approximation
okay so i guess we don't have time for
more questions so let's uh thank the
speaker okay thank you very much for
calling attention